[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Laurent jacobéi bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous despé de la Moselle
porte-parole du rassemblement national
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse régionale représentée par Julien
lesciller de la voie du Nord bonjour
Julien bonjourian bonjour monsieur le
député bonjour et on a donc appris hier
que la Cour de Justice de la République
avait relaxé le garde des saau Éric
Dupont moréti qui était en procès pour
prise illégale d'intérêt est-ce que pour
vous c'est une décision politique non je
crois pas je crois que la justice s'est
prononcée et que notre rôle de
parlementaire n'est pas de critiquer ou
de commenter une décision de justice en
revanche il faut le dire c'est une très
mauvaise nouvelle pour les Français
parce que on va continuer à supporter
monsieur Dupont Moretti comme ministre
de la Justice or c'est un ministre
terrifiant terrifiant par son bilan qui
est terrible hein je le rappelle pas
assez de place de prison et pratiquement
aucune place de prison créé depuis qu'il
est en poste des peines non appliqué
c'est le Ministre des voyou contre le
contre les honnet gens et puis c'est
surtout le ministre qui déteste la
démocratie qui insulte le premier parti
d'opposition le rassemblement national
c'est une espèce d'incongrué
démocratique et dont on aurait été très
heureux excusez-moi les termes de se
débarrasser au gouvernement pour que en
frein les Français puissent être
protégés de leur quotidien et fassent
qu'on arrête en France la
politiquesieurob l'incongruité ou
l'incompétence n'est pas encore un délit
pénal
mais c'est un dél politique presque
alors c'est pas encore rible du point de
vue de la loi est-ce que vous entendez
cette critique qui est faite à la Cour
de Justice de la République d'ê une
justice de l'entreoi une justice
exceptionnelle on l'entend et c'est vrai
qu'il y a probablement des choses à
améliorer en revanche dire que les
ministres sont sujets au droit commun
pose une autre question celle du pouvoir
des juges c'est-à-dire que si certains
juges veulent se faire un ministre alors
il pourrait le faire donc je pense qu'il
faut une solution particulière c'est ce
qui a été trouvé avec la Cour de Justice
de la République on peut maintenant la
réformer on peut
probablement travailler mais mais pas la
supprimer peut-être un peu plus de
transparence peut-être un peu plus
d'écoute des des parties prenantes et de
ceux qui ont porté plainte tout cela
doit être revu probablement mais je
pense que le vrai problème que pose
cette question n'est n'est pas celui-là
c'est l'attitude de Monsieur Dupont
morétique est quelqu'un clairement de de
violant dans ses actes et dans ses
propos et qui s'est mis à dos une partie
des magistrats une partie de l'opinion
française et la moitié de l'Assemblée
nationale ça pose quand même question
pour exercer son mandat un peu vous
parlez de vous un peu moins de la moitié
du coup on va revenir sur sur les propos
d'Éric Duti vous avez une dernière
question Julien avant de revenir
là-dessus oui parce que le le éc duupont
moriti vous l'avez vous l'avez
dit est intervenu d'une façon assez
véhéante au SE hordurière c'est votre
mot au sein de l'hémicycle vous avez
Marine Le Pen avait promis de déposer
une plainte est-ce que c'est le cas euh
je sais pas si c'est fait physiquement
mais en tout cas nous sommes à l'étude
et ce sera fait euh évidemment parce que
nous n'allons pas nous laisser nous
insulter mais au-delà de nous nous
n'allons pas laisser ce ministre
insulter 13 millions d'électeurs de
Marine Le Pen mais juste sur quelle base
pénale la peinte parce que comme le dit
Julien l'insulte c'est pas répréhensible
par la loi bah si quand même on n pas le
droit d'insulter publiquement on n pas
le droit de
trait qu'est- qu'il a dit qu' serait
réible
pénal TR permettre de terminer quand
même si vous voulez on a un ministre qui
ne parle pas qui éructe on a un ministre
qui ne répond pas aux questions mais qui
V sa haine c'est quand même un vrai
problème la question que lui a lui a
posé la députée du rassemblement
national était qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour
qu'il n'y ait plus de petit Thomas
demain qui soit tué à coup de couteau
par des voyou et sa réponse a été une
diatrip contre le rassemblement national
il a montré là deux choses d'abord son
incapacité à supporter la contradiction
et deuxièmement son incompétence ça veut
dire qu'il n'a rien à proposer il est
clairement le ministre des racailles
celui qui défend ceux qui nous attaquent
et le ministre qui n F de la liberté
d'expression et notamment dans
l'émicycle parlementaire que sur quoi
vous allez l'attaquer écoutez on peut
convaincre on peut on peut débattre
insulter c'est autre chose je crois que
ce ministre a monté là a montré là les
limites ses limites républicaines et ses
limites de compétences nous l'attaqurons
parce que nous ne supportons plus que
des millions d'électeurs soient insultés
par des
incompét quand vous dites quand vous
dites monsieur jacobelli qu'il est le
ministre des racailles est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas exactement dans la même
configuration que le ministre quand il
dit chasser de Vang les gudards les
Identitaires les nazons les racistes et
les antisémites vous êtes dans la même
outrance non dans un cas c'est faux
celui dans les paroles prononcées par le
ministre dans l'autre c'est vrai
malheureusement je vous rappelle que
Monsieur Dupont moréti est celui qui
s'est fait acclamer à freine par des
délinquants et des meurtriers il est
celui qui explique qu'il est là pour
défendre les repris de justice il est
celui dont le bilan terrible est qu'il y
a aujourd'hui 85000 peines prononcées
non exécuté il n'a pas créé de place de
prison monsieur Dupont Moretti a un
bilan catastrophieque on peut rappeler
aussi au rassemblement national qu'elle
a eu effectivement et objectivement des
des relations avec les les les gudards
et les Identitaires mais on peut aussi
se replonger dans les années 80 vous
avez mais c'est ce que vous faites
raie un peu de nostalgie pourquoi pas on
est en 2023 en 2023 il y a
l'ensolagement de notre pays il y a des
Français qui ont pas peur de sortir de
chez eux après 21h il y a des jeunes de
16 ans qui se font tuer à coup de
couteau par des bandes de voyou venus de
cité c'est ça la réalité aujourd'hui al
on pourit Aina TR formable Leen au rembl
National clairement elle a pris toutes
les décisions qu'il fallait mais on peut
ne pas la réalité la réalité aujourd'hui
c'est ça alors on peut chercher
effectivement à allumer des contrefeux
mais la réalité et le taux d'insécurité
devenu insupportable pour 89 % des
Français qui pensent que la justice est
trop laxiste mais est-ce que vous n'avez
pas fait de la com avec cette plantete
en quoi la justice peut intervenir sur
des propos tenus dans un hémicycle mais
nous verrons bien vous n'êtes pas juge
moi non plus CJR justement devra se
prononcer nous nous élaborons le dossier
qui sera présenté mais croyez-moi on ne
peut pas impunément insulter la
représentation nationale on va parler de
bah de crpole oui du drame de de crpol
qui n'en finit pas justement d'alimenter
la chronique politique notamment le
ministre de l'Intérieur Gérald hermanin
a annoncé sa volonté de dissoudre trois
grouuscules de l'ultra droite est-ce que
vous soutenez cette cette annonce oui et
d'ailleurs Marine Le Pen avait écrit à
Madame borne l'année dernière pour lui
demander de dissoudre tous les groupes
violents qu'il soi d'ultra droite
d'ultra gauche ultra écolo parce que
effectivement le le devoir du ministre
de l'intérieur est de faire en sorte
qu'on vive en sécurité dans notre pays
et qu'il n'y ait pas des bandes armées
quel que soi leurs opinions politiques
mais attention il faut pas que l'arbre
cache la forêt aujourd'hui la France
n'est pas assailli par des groupuscules
d'extrême droite aujourd'hui ceux qui
tuent ce sont pas les membres de
l'extrême droite le jeune Thomas n'a pas
été tué par des membres de l'extrême
droite aujourd'hui ce qui menace notre
sécurité notre quotidien c'est ce qui se
passe dans certaines cités notamment à
cause d'une immigration mal contrôlée
d'une assimilation qui n'a plus lieu
dans notre pays il y a aujourd'hui des
zones de non France dans certaines cités
des communautés qui vivent contre la
communauté nationale et ça il faut le
dire et ne pas vouloir régler ce
problèmel et bien un problème ce
gouvernement en fait essaie d'allumer
des contrefeux donc oui c'est bien
d'avoir une justice rapide sévère contre
les groupuscules d'ultra droite bravo
mais il faut l'avoir aussi d'ailleurs
pour les groupuscules d'ultra gauche et
il faut l'avoir surtout pour ces
délinquants ces voyous et maintenant ces
meurtriers qui viennent les qui viennent
empêcher les Français de vivre
tranquillement chez eux il représent
selon vous toujours ces mouvement
d'ultra droite ce sont des ozau comme
dirait Marine Le Pen Marion maréchal
Marion maréchal Marion maréchal maréchal
non mais attendez honnêtement l'espèce
de de pseudo expédition punitive à roman
suriser de 30 gars voilà bon écoutez
voilà c'est condamnaable ils sont
condamnés tant mieux qu'est-ce que vous
voulez que je vous dise aujourd'hui
clairement il y aurait selon certains
spécialistes entre 2000 et 4000 membres
de ce qu'on appelle l'ultra droite en
France il y a des dizaines de milliers
de jeunes qui sont en voie
d'islamisation radicale et qui
participent à des trafics de drogu
honnêtement il faut gérer les priorités
mais est-ce que comme Olivier verrant
vous parlez d'un d'un risque de
basculement de la société aujourd'hui je
crois qu'il faut tout faire en tout cas
pour l'éviter nous notre vision de la
France est une nation unie d'ailleurs
avec tous ses concitoyens quel que soit
leurs couleur de peau et leurs origines
je vois que le gouvernement souvent et
Monsieur Moretti d'ailleurs qualifi les
gens en fonction de de leurs prénom et
et de leurs origines ou pas mais il y a
aujourd'hui des gens qui font sécession
en France qui ont parfois des papiers
français mais qui détestent la France et
il faut se poser la question comment en
est-on arrivé là bah il y a un cocktail
explosif laxisme judiciaire et
immigration incontrôlée qui donne
aujourd'hui cette situation qui font que
oui les Français ont peur quand on voit
les derniers sondages les français se
sentent en insécurité dans leur propre
pays et donc clairement monsieur Dupont
mariti n'a pas fait le travail il faut
aujourd'hui une justice plus ferme et un
contrôle très strict de l'immigration en
France on va parler projet de la
immigration justement oui parlons du
projet de loi immigration il est
toujours en examen à la commission des
lois et ce jusqu'à dimanche la
commission des lois justement un rétabli
dans le dans le texte l'aide médicale
d'État laame transformé en aide
d'urgence par le Sénat est-ce que
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette
décision non mais je crois que
clairement on voit bien que la macronie
et l'extrême gauche ont la même
politique immigrationniste en fait pour
eux l'immigration est un choix voilà
pour nous c'est quelque chose que nous
subissons qu'il faut contrôler bah parce
que quand on crée des filières
d'immigration légal ou illégal c'est
qu'on veut de l'immigration quand on dit
à la terentière venez en France
illégalement et faites-vous soigner bah
clairement on va pas régler le problème
de l'immigration c'est pas ce que disent
les les soignants vous souvenez de cette
tribune signé par 3500 d'entre eux qui
disaient qu'il y avait au travers de
l'aide médicale la la volonté aussi de
soigner des des gens au même titre que
que des Français et surtout de prévenir
des épidémies fait faire de la
prévention ça vous n'y êtes pas sensible
ils sont dans le rôle voilà il y le
serment d'Hippocrate et clairement le
serment d'Hippocrate dit que on doit
soigner tout le monde nous nous sommes
des politiques et on doit faire en sorte
que cette submersion migratoire s'arrête
et donc clairement quand on dit à
quelqu'un si vous arrivez illégalement
en France on vous soignera de la tête au
pied ça pose un problème que maintenant
il y ait des soins d'urgence c'est ce
que nous avons toujours proposé
d'ailleurs
pour pour les maladies plutôt oui pour
les maladies contagieuses évidemment
d'abord on va pas laisser quelqu'un
mourir qu'il soit légal en situation
légale ou illégale évidemment et on ne
va pas laisser des maladies se propager
en revanche envoyer le signal comme on
le fait aujourd'hui la France est
devenue un hôtel un hôpital et un
restaurant venez comme vous êtes c'est
pas possible c'est pas possible parce
que des gens arrivent pour les mauvaises
raisonsz moi j'ai connu une immigration
on onevenenait en France pour travailler
par adhésion à la culture et à
l'histoire française et par respect voir
admiration pour ce pays c'était le cas
de mes grands-parents il y a aujourd'hui
une immigration d'opportunité qui veut
utiliser les aides sociales ou se faire
soigner cette immigration on voit bien
les conséquences néfastes qu'elle a sur
la société française et donc le rôle du
poli mais est-ce que du coup vous
défendrez le rétablissement de la mu
comme l'a voté le Sénat non mais
aujourd'hui il faut arrêter avec la me
et avoir des soins de dispensaire des
soins d'urgence oui ça a toujours été
notre proposition nous avons toujours
été clair là-dessus mais c ce projet de
loi d'immigration qui dit venez en
France illégalement et travaillez
illégalement et on vous régularisera ou
bien venez vous faire soigner
honnêtement c'est la porte ouverte à
toujours plus d' que la la la rédaction
nouvelle trouvée autour de l'article 4
bis qui justement traite de la régul
isation des sans-piers dans les métiers
en tension ça ne vous satisfait toujours
pas je rappelle en fait l'idée désormais
de la rédaction ce serait de de donner
de continuer de de donner un pouvoir au
préfet mais de simplement de refuser
quand c'est motivé hein quand il trouve
une motivation plus d'automaticité plus
d'automaticité moi je je je je je vois
bien l'énergie de Monsieur daranin et du
gouvernement de de s'occuper des
migrants et notamment des migrants
illégaux en priorité nous on aimerait
bien qu'on s'intéresse en priorité au
français il y a aujourd'hui 5,4 million
de chômeurs en France voilà il y a des
salaires qui sont trop bas parfois pour
permettre à des gens de vivre nous ce
que nous proposons c'est que plutôt que
de dire àtiron toute la misère du monde
pour tirer les salaires vers le bas de
manière
maintenant dit comme vous il dit aussi
que ça serait bien que ce soit les
françaisés il est président de la
République alors qu'il agisse nous on
lui fait une proposition très claire
avec Marine Le Pen et Jordane Bardella
si un employeur augmente les salaires de
10 % ces 10% sont exonérés de charge
patronale ça permettra de rendre les
métiers plus attractif c'est pas
question de salaire vous entendez les
patrons c'est pas uniquement une
question de salaire moi j'entends les
patrons qui nous disent parfois c'est
aussi une question de pénibilité des
tâches écoutez les patrons nous disent
les patrons nous disent qu'ils
préféreraient engager des Français ou
des étrangers d'ailleurs en situation
régulière avec le droit de travailler en
France or aujourd'hui puisqu'il y a
cette ce chemin échappatoire et bien
certains pas tous mais certains en
profitent pour tirer les salaires vers
le bas et utiliser voire exploiter une
maindœvre étrangère en sit situation
illégale je pense que c'est
contrairement à ce que disent un certain
nombre d'hommes politiques d'ultra
gauche ou d'ultra centre ce n'est pas
humaniste c'est au contraire créer une
forme d'esclavagisme moderne contre
lequel nous sommes clairement il y
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres mesures tout
de même qui pourrai trouver votre
agrément Dans ce projet de loi écoutez
je pense que ce projet de loi il a
maintenant révélé sa vraie nature c'est
comment faire de l'immigration illégale
une immigration légale ça ne nous
intéresse pas ça c'est la version que
vous en faites parce qu'il y a des
mesures très fermes sera sans nous nous
nous proposons c'est un référendum parce
qu'il faut un Pact entre la nation et
ses dirigeants sur la question
migratoire les Français n'ont jamais été
interrogés là-dessus ce référendum il
est rédigé Marine Le Pen avait proposé à
l'élection présidentielle la fin du
droit du sol rendre le regroupement
familial plus difficile la fin des
allocations social sur quelle base
constitutionnelle parce que les le la
Constitution à l'heure actuelle n'admet
pas des des des référendum sur des
questions autres que social éc votre
analyse le président de la République
aujourd'hui n'aurait pas le droit d'êre
président la République parce que
clairement ça s'est fait l'élection du
Président de la République au suffrage
universel par un référendum du général
de gaaule donc si bien sûr Emmanuel
Macron dans les deuxièes rencontres de
Saint- il a fermé la porte au référendum
mais c'est bien le problème donc on
attendra 2027 et l'élection de Marine Le
Pen pour faire ce référendum mais nous
le ferons nous le ferons parce que les
Français n'en peuvent plus de cette
immigration qui n'est plus contrôlé qui
polluent leur vie quotidienne pour des
questions de sécurité d'emploi et donc
il faut maintenant remett question
au cur du débat vous voulez donner la
parole au français écouter les Français
vous voyez dans dans les sondages les
Français ils sont favorables à ce projet
de loi immigration du coup pourquoi vous
ne le votez pas mais parce que parce que
nous sommes contre parce que nous
pensons qu'on a menti au français c'est
que c'est toujours la même technique
c'est monsieur daranin qui vient et qui
fait le Matamort et qui dit moi j'ai
compris plus de sécurité moins
d'immigration dans les faits
l'insécurité explose sous monsieur
Darmanin et l'immigration va exploser
comme elle a déjà explosé ce que vous
nous dites monsieur jacobini c'est que
quel que soit d'ailleurs l'issue des
discussions en commission des lois vous
ne vous abstiendrez même pas ce sera
forcément à votre contre écoutez on va
voir la suite des débats nous nous
sommes pragmatiques mais enfin il y a
déjà deux lignes rouges qui ont été
franchis la régularisation des des
illégaux qui travaillent et laame mais
c'est aussi une ligne rouge ici au Sénat
donc il y aura une commission mixte
paritaire un accord c'est pour ça que je
ne vous donne pas une réponse définitive
mais enfin entre nous c'est quand même
mal parti pour que nous votions ce texte
qui je le répète est plutôt un texte
pour favoriser l'immigration légale et
illégale que de le contrôler il y a 17
députés les républicains qui dans une
tribune dans la tribune dimanche ont dit
qu'ils voulaient être constructif sur ce
texte est-ce que du coup selon vous le
gouvernement pourrait éviter le 493 mais
j'adore j'adore mes collègues les
républicains c'est-à-dire que ils sont
un peu à l'image de Monsieur Darmanin
d'ailleurs il en vient c'est-à-dire
qu'ils ont un discours très dur sur les
plateau de télévision ou dans la
circonscription et puis au final la
soupe est tellement bonne on se range
toujours du côté du gouvernement je
crois qu'ils ont une ils ont la trouille
au ventre la trouille de retourner
devant les électeurs en cas de
dissolution et de voir leur siège passer
à quelqu'un d'autre donc clairement ils
ne sont pas objectifs non je pense que
les Français ont compris que les
républicains étaient la la béquille du
gouvernement qui avait aujourd'hui une
seule véritable opposition constructive
et de bon sens la question subsidiaire
c'est en effet ce soutien une éventuelle
motion de sensure est-ce que vous la
voteriez motion de censure vous savez
nous les avons pratiquement tout voté
depuis le début nous pensons que ce
gouvernement agit contre l'intérêt des
Français et donc s'il faut le censurer
nous le ferons bien évidemment donc si
l'air dépose motion de censure elle aura
les 88 vois du RN ah oui a priori oui et
autre question puisque ça ça concerne
aussi les républicains ils défendront le
7 décembre une proposition de loi
constitutionnelle qui vise à déroger des
règles européennes et d'ouvrir justement
ce fameux article 11 dont on parlait de
la Constitution pour lui permettre
d'intégrer les questions autour de
l'immigration ça aussi vous soutiendrez
écoutez nous verrons le texte pour
l'instant nous nous pensons qu'on peut
déjà faire un référendum sur
l'immigration puisque les questions
économiques et sociales font partie du
champ du référendum et que nous pensons
que l'immigration a un impact très fort
sur l'économie et le social maintenant
nous é dirons texte nous le faisons
d'ailleurs pour tous les textes qui
émanent de tous les groupes de
l'Assemblée nationale vous savez nous
nous n'avons qu'une boussole c'est là
vous avez vraiment besoin de de
l'examiner je veux dire c'est assez
clair dans les motifs non non mais on
verra effectivement comment ilc non mais
je vais vous dire c'est compliqué de
soutenir les LR non pas du tout non mais
je vous dis une fois encore nous avons
même voté parfois des amendements ou des
textes de la France soumise et je vous
assure que pour quelqu'un qui aime la
démocratie la République c'est compliqué
mais simplement nous devrons arbitrer
est-ce que c'est une reconnaissance du
fait que l'article 11 ne nous
permettrait pas aujour auourd'hui de
faire ce référendum au quel cas c'est
gênant où est-ce que ça fait vraiment
passer les choses maintenant faut voir
aussi le positionnement de ce texte dans
la liste de la niche je voudrais pas
être trop technique mais parfois vous
savez on placee des textes d'opportunité
en fin de liste pour faire de la com
mais pas pour faire de la loi on parle
de l'accord oui puisque en effet selon
les informations du du Figaro l'exécutif
serait prêt à renégocier l'accord
FrancoAlgérien sur l'immigration c'est
en
1968 sous la pression des des
républicains et des d'douard Philippe
est-ce que ce serait une bonne chose et
il faut revoir absolument cet accord
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans une une
situation insoutenable où nous recevons
euh un certain nombre d'Algériens qui
est une une des nations qui apportent le
plus de migrants euh à la France parce
que les visas sont simples il y a une
procédure allégée pour les Algériens
pour venir en France en revanche quand
il y a un Algérien frappé d'une
obligation de quitter le territoire
français là pour le coup il y a pas de
visa diplomatique dans l'autre sens pour
que nous puissions euh renvoyer les
Algériens qui ont commis des crimes et
délit donc nous sommes dans une
situation intenable les relations avec
l'Algérie sont catastrophiques et
pourtant hein monsieur Darmanin est allé
déposer une gerbe de fleur devant le
tombeau des terroristes du FLN nous
mettons un genou à terre tous les 4atre
matins en faisant repentance et bien on
voit bien que cette espèce de soumission
ne marche pas donc il va falloir essayer
autre chose et casser cet accord et
probablement une bonne voie et justement
est-ce que la la crainte ce n'est pas en
tentant de renégocier cet accord
FrancoAlgérien de provoquer une nouvelle
crise avec Alger enfin excusez-moi elle
est là la crise donc autant faire en
sorte de déf défendre les Français
aujourd'hui al les Français n peuvent
plus non plus cette cette filière
d'immigration complètement incontrôlée
avec un certain nombre d'Algériens je je
ne voudrais pas dire de bêtises mais qui
sont dans le top 3 des TF c'estàd les
obligations à quitter le territoire mais
qui ne sont jamais renvoyer chez eux
donc il a un moment ça pose un problème
clairement ce problème il faut le régler
évidemment je je je ne dis pas que tous
les Algériens qui vivent en France sont
en situation IR régulière ni même qu'ils
sont des dé linquant je ne dis pas ça
mais je dis que c'est malheureusement
avec l'Algérie que nous avons un
problème pour le retour de CACC entendu
autre sujet Laurent Nunez le préfet de
police de Paris sera auditionné au Sénat
cet après-midi parce que les sénateurs
s'interrogent voir s'inquiètent des
mesures qui ont été annoncé dans la
presse de restriction de circulation et
de sécurisation des j avec notamment
l'instauration d'un QR code pour
circuler pendant les les Jeux Olympiques
est-ce que vous partagez ces inquiétudes
oui bien sûr d'abord on nous amène cette
idée de de QR code sorti d'un chapeau
alors qu'il y a quelques mois nous avons
voté à au Parlement pour les les les
mesures à mettre en place pour les les
Jeux Olympiques il n'y avait pas ce QR
code donc on voit bien qu'il y a une
forme d'impréparation d'improvisation
euh c'est très inquiétant pour des
questions de liberté publique après il
faudra savoir le contour de ce QR code
enfin la vie des Parisiens et des
franciliens et si j'en crois les
témoignages déjà extrêmement compliqué
presque invivable alors ça va devenir
l'enfer alors que ça doit être un moment
de fête mais surtout ça pose une
question où en est-on de la sécurisation
de ces Jeux Olympiques parce que je vois
qu'il manque à peu près 20000 personnels
de sécurité privé euh c'est quand même
très inquiétant parce que c'est dans
quelques mois je vois qu'il y a 35000
personnels des forces de l'ORD qui vont
être mobilisés à Paris et sur les lieux
de de compétition mais qu'on va prendre
où qu'on va prendre dans les territoires
ces mêmes territoires qui sont déjà en
proie aujourd'hui à une explosion des
violences corporelles des cambriolages
et donc les réservistes notamment donc
on va appeler les réservistes mais on
voit bien qu'on arrive au bout du bout
d'une logique et qu'on VO ça sent quand
même très fortement l' préparation et
c'est ça qui est inquiétant et on l'a
bien vu pendant la crise du covid
malheureusement quand le gouvernement
n'est n'est pas prêt il atteint aux
libertés publiques des citoyens j'espère
qu'on prend pas le même chemin il faud
qu'est-ce que vous attendez du coup
deounes cet aprèsmidi de cette audition
clairement qui nous explique dans le
détail ce phénomène de QR code qu'est-ce
qu'il faudra remplir sur internet pour
l'obtenir est-ce que il y aura des
informations qui concernent la vie
privée mais surtout j'espère qu'il va
nous rassurer est-ce que les forces de
l'ordre qui seront prises dans les
territoir vont être compensés d'une
manière ou d'une autre est-ce qu'on aura
assez de forces de sécurité privée pour
faire les comp contrôle j'ai entendu
dire que on allait se tourner vers des
pays étrangers pour avoir ses vigiles
j'allais dire du quotidien et privé dont
certains ne parleraient pas français
tout cela m'a l'air d'être un gloubiouga
absolument indigeste et pas du tout
contrôlé j'espère que Monsieur nunz
répondra à ces questions et est-ce que
vous souhaitez que Gérald Harman soit
auditionné est-ce que vous souhaitez
l'uditionner ça paraî une évidence que
le ministre de l'intérieur doit se
prononcer bien sûr Israël oui vous êtes
membre de la commission de de la défense
à l'Assemblée nationale la trve a été
prolongé a-t-on appris jusqu'à vendredi
euh c'est un signe d'optimisme à voir je
suis partagé pour être très honnête il y
a des signes d'optimisme c'est la
libération d'un certain nombre d'otage
et notamment de femmes et d'enfants et
quand on voit la la joie des familles
qui
récupèrent ceux qui étaient retenus par
le Hamas ou d'autres groupes terroristes
islamistes évidemment c'est un
soulagement il y a quand même beaucoup
d'inquiétude aussi beaucoup d'inquiétude
parce que certains ne sont toujours pas
libérés on se pose des questions
sont-ils toujours en vie la question se
pose notamment pour la famille Bibas et
les deux enfants un petit de de 10 mois
et un de de 4 ans et puis ça pose des
questions aussi sur le territoire
national puisque vous savez que le Front
Populaire de Libération de la Palestine
serait un des groupes terroristes qui
détiendrait des otages au côté du Hamas
or ce même FPLP est reçu en grande pompe
en France par des membres de l'Assemblée
national et des députés la France
insoumise ils les ont reçu ils les ont
accueillis à l'aéroport ils ont
manifesté pour que madame Abou Daka ne
soit pas renvoyé chez elle alors que
c'est un mouvement terroriste et donc de
voir qu'il y a des ramifications dans la
politique française qu' y a des
porte-paroles des terroristes islamistes
à l'Assemblée nationale est très
inquiétant c'est très inquiétant sur
l'importation du conflit et ça raisonne
avec le nombre il faudit des sanctionsel
vousz cont contre les Français de
confession juiv si vous le soulevez
c'est que vous pensez qu'il y a des
sanctions à avoir vis-à-vis des députés
et les filles qui se commettent aveces
organisation bah en tout cas on voit
madame souet qui est député la France
insoumise qui dans une interview filmée
ne comprend pas qu'on lui interdise
d'inviter des gens de ce groupe
terroriste et qui rigolent à l'évocation
du du 7 octobre donc tout cela est très
inquiétant ça mérite quand même une une
vraie vigilance surtout quand on voit
sur les plateaux de télévision que il
mentre comme Monsieur bonpard en disant
on ne sait pas ce que c'est que le FPLP
or il travaille avec clairement il
l'amène à l'Assemblée nationale donc
tout cela est effectivement très
inquiétant merci lur Jacob merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité la une
de la voie du Nord après les inondations
des risques de pollution oui une
catastrophe n'arrivant jamais seul c'est
la Question à la Une de votre journal
Julien merci beaucoup Julien la semaine
prochaine on passe au club des
territoires